Major breaking news as a huge legal
lawsuit challenging the Hughes Amendment
922, which prevents ordinary Americans
from possessing post 1986 machine guns,
has just been filed in federal court in
Texas by the Temple Gun Club down there
and some other plaintiffs. We're going
to break down this lawsuit, his
possibility of winning, and a few other
observations when we come right back.
Hey folks, I'm Mark Smith, host of the
four box of Dina, proud American gun
owner, constitutional attorney, member
of the United States Supreme Court Barn,
and I'm proud to say the top voice of
the Second Amendment in America. Thank
you both 2025 and 2026 Gundy's Awards.
All right, folks. So, there's a huge
lawsuit that's just been filed down
there in the state of Texas in federal
court in the Northern District of Texas
on behalf of several plaintiffs,
including the Temple Gun Club and
several of its members, claiming that
they want to be able to possess post
1986 machine guns andor to convert their
existing semi-automatic rifles into post
1986 machine guns. They are laser
focused on congressional authority under
article one of the constitution claiming
there is no article one authority under
the constitution that gives congress to
gives congress or the federal government
for that matter the authority to ban
post 1986 machine guns and there is no
jurisdictional hook to that 1986 law
known as the Hughes amendment which is
part of the firearms owners protection
act specifically federal gun control law
section 18 USC C 922.
Now, we've covered this 922 quite a bit
uh recently because of discussions in
places like West Virginia about whether
or not to modify their state laws and
allow law enforcement agencies in the
state to transfer post 1986 machine guns
to ordinary Americans. Um that has been
tabled for the moment because that
legislation or those legislative efforts
for the moment don't seem to be moving
with any speed anywhere. But that
doesn't mean they're dead. It just means
uh that they're just getting up and
running, I suspect. But with that said,
there's a lawsuit here down there in
Texas that laser focuses, as I see it,
on arguing, which is correct, which is
correct, that there is no article one
jurisdiction to justify or allow
constitutionally
Congress to enact the Hughes Amendment.
Now, just to step back for the moment,
and then we'll get back into the details
of this lawsuit. Remember how I've
explained to you over and over and over
again that if you want to be the best
second amendment advocate in the
America, if you want to be a star second
amendment advocate and go beyond just
mouthing the word shall not be
infringed, you're required not only to
understand second amendment
juristprudence, but you must understand
how the entire constitutional structure
works to protect all of our rights and
all of our freedoms. that includes
understand the inter relationship and
the powers and authority under article
one, article two and article three of
the US constitution. Article one of the
constitution creates the congressional
authority with enumerated powers as to
what congress can act enact in terms of
laws and what it cannot. Article two of
creates the presidency of the United
States and the powers of the executive
branch. And article three of course
creates the Supreme Court and lower
courts. And you have to understand how
these three interrelate to be the best
possible second amendment advocate. And
you're going to see specifically how
this all interrelates in this particular
case. Because this lawsuit down in Texas
is going to give rise not only to
questions about article one authority by
Congress. is actually going to give rise
to questions about article 3, article 3
authority by the federal court system as
to whether or not this constitutes a
case and controversy which is required
to get into federal court. But we'll get
to that in one moment. Now, with that
said, this lawsuit is very well crafted
uh very well done and it starts off the
way it should be describing the Hughes
Act or the Hughes amendment, I should
say, 922 as something that was enacted
in 1996 at the last minute with a voice
call or voice vote. uh proposed by the
New Jersey congressman Mr. Hughes I
believe which is why it's called the
Hughes amendment and how there was no
real debate about this other than a
single statement not that the debate
should be considered because that's
legislative history and legislative
history as a general matter is not
allowed when you interpret the
constitution at least with this Supreme
Court. Now, with that said, after
describing the Hughes Amendment,
pointing out that ordinary Americans
cannot uh acquire post 1986 machine
guns, it then goes on to talk about how
article one of the constitution doesn't
speak to any of these issues. Here's how
it starts off. There are 17 specific
powers enumerated in article 1 section 8
of the constitution along with the power
to make all laws which shall be
necessary and proper for carrying into
execution the foregoing powers and all
of the powers vested by this
constitution in the government of the
United States or in any department or
officer thereof. The power to prohibit
possessing a firearm is neither
implicitly nor explicitly among the
federal government's powers. To the
contrary, the drafters of the
Constitution included a direct
prohibition on infringing upon the right
to keep and bear arms. Indeed, the
Constitution expressly delegates to
Congress authority over only four
specific crimes. Counterfeiting
securities and coin in the United
States, piracies and felonies committed
on the high seas, offenses against the
law of nations, and treason. Section 922
does not fall within any of the crimes
specified in Taylor, which is a case
referencing to what I just described. So
having laid out the basics of article
one of the constitution which is of
course the correct way of doing it goes
on to point out that allowing congress
to exceed these runs the risk of running
a foul or infringing upon all sorts of
American freedoms. That's not how the
constitutional structure was structured
as Justice Scalia for example on this
very channel I played some clips from
him pointing out that what makes America
special and protects our freedoms is not
the bill of rights. It's not the Bill of
Rights. Every single crazy nuts job
country in the world, including the
Soviet Union when it existed, had a bill
of rights. All sorts of great rights.
But remember, we've talked about this
before. There is no right without a
remedy. Repeat after me. There is no
right without a remedy. I can say you
have a right, but if you have no way to
enforce that right, you have no rights.
So again, write this down. Important for
you to know, important for you to say if
you're involved with any of the stuff.
There is no right without a remedy. And
that goes with contract rights. He goes
with constitutional rights, it doesn't
matter. If you cannot enforce a right,
you have no right. The remedy is how you
enforce a right. If you have no right,
if you have no remedy, you have no
right. No rights without remedies.
Always remember that. So if the courts
don't enforce, for example, the second
amendment, you have no second amendment
rights. That's the reality on the
ground. Nevertheless, here's what the
complaint goes on to say by the Temple
Gun Club and its members. The greatest
enduring stronghold of the American
experiment is that the federal
government is one of limited enumerated
powers. Any power that is not expressly
delegated to the federal government is
reserved to the states and the people.
Congress has no power to enact a
comprehensive criminal code. Thus, any
power of Congress to criminalize a
person's conduct must be grounded in
another enumerated power. Most often
most often Congress claims to find the
power rooted in the interstate commerce
clause. But the commerce clause does not
grant federal jurisdiction over every
item capable of being bought or sold.
The Supreme Court of the United States
has limited the commerce clause to
regulating the channels
instrumentalities of interstate
commerce. That all sounds good to me.
And again, just to step back for a
moment, article one of the Constitution,
which creates Congress's enumerated
powers to act, and if it's not there,
they're not allowed to act. There's two
things to always keep in mind when
you're talking about federal gun crimes.
One is Congress's power to tax, which
gave rise to the National Firearms Act,
which is that that was a taxing scheme.
Okay.
The other one is Congress has the
authority to regulate interstate
commerce. Commerce among the states,
commerce among the United States and
foreign governments in foreign
countries. And it is those are the two
possible hooks to justify gun control
laws. And that's just the reality on the
ground because in the Hughes amendment,
there is no taxing component. In fact,
there's no component either of taxing or
interstate commerce. Um there's no
jurisdictional hook. Now, you don't need
to look to Mark Smith at the Four Boxes
Diner, although that's not a terrible
source. I think a better source is
Supreme Court Justice Samuel Alo when he
was on the uh Court of Appeals for the
Third Circuit out of New Jersey,
Delaware, and Pennsylvania when he
dissented in a case called the United
States versus Rybar pointed out exactly
this that the Hughes amendment 922 has
no jurisdictional hook to taxation or to
interstate commerce. And he goes through
that in great detail. And this
complaint, I'm happy to report
references that judge uh then judge
Alto, now Justice Alo descent and Rybar
pointing out indeed 18 USC922
has no article 1 jurisdictional hook
either by virtue of congressional
findings of fact during the hearings or
u in the actual language itself. The
proper way to draft something like this
is to literally write into the statute
that this only applies to firearms and
say in interstate commerce or something
along those lines, but that's not in the
statute. And we know that because for me
to put you in prison as a prosecutor
under the Hughes amendment under the
Hughes Act, right? Whatever you want to
call it. I do not have to prove that the
gun or you or anything about your crime
of possessing an unregistered machine
gun touches fingers with interstate
commerce in any respect. And you still
get to go to prison. And it's because it
doesn't require as an essential element
of the crime some component to
interstate commerce. Well, really
there's no interstate commerce
connection and thus it should be
unconstitutional as pointed out by none
other than then judge now justice Samuel
Alo the author of among other things the
dos opinion that overturned Roie Wade. I
think the reason why the complaint
mentions the United States versus Nson
is it's technically speaking binding
authority within the fifth circuit where
Texas is located and specifically the
fifth circuit in 1997 said that 18UCC922
the Hughes amendment is perfectly
constitutional under the commerce
clause. Here's what they had to write
then. The question is, does the
enactment of 18 USC 922 criminalizing
the transfer or possession of a machine
gun that was not already lawfully
possessed before May 19th, 1996 exceeds
the limit of its power under the
commerce clause? Well, every other
circuit that has considered this issue
has upheld 922 as a rational exercise of
that power, albeit for differing
reasons. Today, we join those circuits
in affirming the constitutionality of
section 922.
Okay, guess what?
Whenever you see lower courts saying
every other court of appeals agrees with
us and we're just going to like, you
know, leapfrog with them. We're just
going to agree with them. You know, you
got a problem. Now, here's the good
news. If you look at the Supreme Court
decision in Heler, every single court of
appeals and lower court basically said
you had no individual right to keep and
bear arms with the exception of like a
couple. There was like the Parker case
and the Emerson case and maybe one
other. That was it. Okay. Every other
federal lower court said that the second
amendment protected a collective right
and no one had a second amendment right
individually which was hoie but that's
what they did. The Supreme Court doesn't
give one iota about these lower courts.
So the fact that every single lower
court agrees on some proposition doesn't
mean the Supreme Court's going to agree
at all because that's how we got to
Heler. Likewise with Breuan, every
single court of appeal said you had no
right to bear arms outside. You had no
right to carry guns in public for
self-defense with the exception of just
the seventh circuit and the DC court of
appeals. That was it. All the others
lined up. You know, if you did the math,
it was overwhelmingly the second
amendment did not protect an indiv
individual right before Heler.
Overwhelmingly, the Second Amendment did
not protect the right to carry guns
before Breuan. And the Supreme Court
spanked them all in the butt and said,
"You guys are out of your minds." So the
point is that the Nson case here saying
that oh every single court of appeals
that ever looked at 18 USC922 says it's
hunky dory imperfectly constitutional
under the non-existent commerce clause
connection. I would not worry about that
other than to acknowledge it, recognize
it, and get around it because this is a
1997. I can assure you the US Supreme
Court today is much better for Second
Amendment and much better on these kinds
of issues than they were back in 1997.
So we'll see what happens there. But I
didn't want to flag the point that this
is another example how brick by brick by
brick, precedent by pre president can
build up. In this case, it works against
us because the fifth circuit in Newton
relied on these other decisions against
922 or I should say in favor of 922
against machine guns to uphold what
happened there. Now with that said, I
want to flag one u area of concern of
this complaint and I'm going to refer to
what be what became the Heler case and
that is the Parker case. Now what am I
talking about here? As you know under
article 3 of the constitution, federal
courts have jurisdiction only only over
certain kinds of cases and those are
cases and controversies based on Supreme
Court president cases and controversies
can only exist if you have an actual
dispute over an actual issue by actual
people. Sometimes this is referred to as
the standing doctrine. Now here there is
an interesting question about standing.
At the time this lawsuit was filed, it
appears that none of the plaintiffs had
sought to acquire the license to permit
them to either make machine guns post
1986 and or to possess them. Okay. The
reason why that is significant is what
they allege in paragraph 101 of this
complaint. Let's check it out, then
we'll talk about it. It would be futile
for plaintiffs to file an ATF form one
to make a machine gun or an ATF form 4
to transfer a machine gun for a post
1986 machine gun because the statutes
and the BATF regulations require the
agency to deny it citing a relevant law.
That's not a crazy thing to say, but
here's the thing. And again, these laws
vary over time and jurisdictions. I'm
not saying I got this right or wrong.
I'm just flagging a potential issue. If
you look at the US Court of Appeals
decision in Parker, that's the US Court
of Appeals decision from the District of
Columbia in Parker before Heler, there
were six different plaintiffs. Listen
carefully. There were six different
plaintiffs.
Five of the plaintiffs lost their Second
Amendment challenge in the DC Court of
Appeals because they wanted to they
wanted to possess handguns in DC, but
they never applied to register a handgun
in DC. There was one exception to that.
What was that exception? Who was that
exception? You know the answer. Dick
Heler. Dick Heler was the only plaintiff
of the six plaintiffs in the Parker
case, which became the Hiller case. In
the Parker case, there were six
plaintiffs. The only one that applied to
get his handgun registered in DC was
Dick Hiller. The court of appeals for
the DC circuit said he's the only one
withstanding under article 3 of the
constitution to pursue his second
amendment claims. 18 months later, Dick
Hiller's case went to the US Supreme
Court and became Heler versus the
District of Columbia and found that the
Second Amendment does indeed protect the
individual right to bear arms. And the
only reason why Dick Heler was able to
become Dick Heler at the Supreme Court
was because he was the one plaintiff of
the six that sought to register his
handgun with DC and received a letter or
whatever it was that says denied. The
other five that were just saying, "Hey,
we want the gun. We want to carry it. We
want to possess the gun." And all that,
that was all uh dismissed. Now, in
fairness, these standing doctrines are
quirky and the fifth circuit might be
more sympathetic. The Supreme Court
stuff poster Heler might be more
sympathetic. That all may be true, but
still it is something we should be
watching as to whether or not uh
whoever's on the other side here, the
government is going to argue that
there's a lack of standing because none
of the plaintiffs applied for and were
denied the license or permission, if you
will, to possess a post 1986 machine
gun. Watch that carefully. And here's
the language out of the Parker case,
which became the Helder case. I know
this very well because the author of
Parker, Judge Larry Silverman, was my
professor at NYU Law School and always
liked me because I got the question
right which was who were the Sullivan
brothers in World War II. And I of
course knew those were the brothers that
were all killed on a single ship that
gave rise to the new rule that you can't
all put a family on one ship. He always
was impressed by that answer and became
a mentor and friend of mine thereafter.
Judge Larry Sberman, author of Parker,
saying there is a second amendment right
to keep him arms and gave rise of course
to Heler and the Scalia decision
therein. But take a look at what Judge
Silverman wrote about this issue of
standing and why Dick Heler had it and
the other five plaintiffs did not in the
Parker case which again was the case
that became Heler 18 months later. The
noteworthy distinction in this case, a
distinction mentioned in appellants's
complaint and pressed by them on appeal
is that appellant Heler has applied for
and been denied a registration
certificate to own a handgun. A fact not
present in Seagars, which is a
presidential case there. The denial of
the gun license is significant. It
constitutes an injury independent of the
district's perspective enforcement of
its gun laws and an injury to which the
stringent requirements for
preinforcement standing under relevant
case law would not apply. Since DC code
and goes on for the section would amount
to further conditions on the certificate
Heler desires, Heler standing to pursue
the license denial would subsume these
other claims too. This is not a new
proposition. We have consistently
treated a license or permit denial. We
have consistently treated a license or
permit denial pursuant to a state or
federal administrative scheme as an
article 3 to the US state's constitution
injury.
So again you can see the importance of
standing which you have to have to have
article 3 standing under the
constitution case or controversy rule
which is set forth in article three of
the constitution that's why this case
presents questions of article one and
article 3 to the US constitution and
again standing whether or not there's
rightness whether or not there's an
injury in fact u these can all be quirky
little questions and uh I'm just
flagging this is something we want to
watch moving forward to see whether or
not the federal government raises is
this kind of argument uh in defense of
the statute. I don't know what they will
do. Maybe they will concede the point. I
just don't know. But it is something we
should pay attention to because what we
never want to do if you want to win a
case at the Supreme Court, you never
want to give Chief Justice John Roberts
an offramp to dodge the merits of the
question on some sort of technical
procedural ground like standing or
rightness or injury or fact or whatever
it is. And that's why uh it's good to
try to touch every single base. And I
don't know if it'd be doable to uh file
such a form with the ATF and get denied
in this context. Uh that's not for me to
figure out, but it is something I'd be
thinking about uh as I track this case
would as it moves forward, which of
course we hope they do indeed succeed.
All right, there you have it, folks.
Hope you enjoyed this episode. I'll try
to put a link to the complaint down
below in the description of this video.
Make sure you follow me over there on
X4box. Don't forget to subscribe both
YouTube and the Rumble. And I'll talk to
you again real soon here at the Forbox
Diner. Orders up. Table 2 A.